there are growing questions about the
data your car is collecting about you
while you're on the road modern vehicles
are packed with powerful computers that
can measure a vehicle's performance and
even tell car makers how and where you
drive now the auto industry is learning
the data is worth big money Kris Van
Cleave is in Miami to explain where that
information manned up Chris good morning
well good morning drivers are opting
into this and I wouldn't say it's time
to wrap your car in tinfoil or anything
like that just yet but vehicles like
this one are increasingly coming
connected this has a Wi-Fi modem onboard
and your car may know a whole lot about
you like where you've been what kind of
music you like to listen to even what
your favorite cup of coffee is and
privacy advocates warned that
information could end up in the hand of
advertisers or your insurance company
we're gonna do is pop the hood under the
hood Ford's former head of tech John
Ellis found four computers it generates
data and it collects data and inside the
car we're gonna go ahead and connect
this underneath he hooked up his
smartphone to show us the data streaming
in real time with enough data I can
discern patterns that seem to be almost
non-existent to the human eye from the
brakes to the windshield wipers with as
many as 100 points that generate data
bumper-to-bumper today's cars pack the
power of 20 personal computers and can
process up to 25 gigs of data every hour
some of it beamed back to car makers and
now they're rushing to turn your car's
data into a revenue stream reselling
blocks of location information and
one-day info from the cars onboard
cameras and sensors could be bought by
mapping companies or apps that monitor
traffic conditions something nearly
seventy two percent of car owners said
they had no idea was happening
we know how tired you are cuz we have
cameras inside the car looking at the
driver to look for eyelid movement some
of the cars have the ability to detect
alcohol are you weaving are you moving
are you harsh braking and how hard you
brake could get you a break on car
insurance
good drivers who agree to share data can
get a better deal and the drive for data
is big business soon a car's data may be
worth more than the vehicle itself
according to one car data company and up
to
quarters of a trillion dollars
industry-wide by 2030 your driving
behavior the person in the car we do
have that data GM uses that data with
drivers consent to put popular brands at
their fingertips you've created this
connection with merchants and brands
they know your data we're bringing that
onto the dashboard of the car
GM calls it marketplace an attempt to
cash in on the 46 minutes a day the
average American spends in a car low on
gas it'll point to the closest gas
station and let you pay from the - where
you can also order food or make
reservations on the go our newest find
and reserve all based on what's close to
the cars current location click reserve
now you and I have a reservation at 1:15
at Samba kitchen and it sent to my email
but GM says drivers are asked offends
what does the opt-in process look like
how does that work when you get into
your car after you've purchased it the
very first time then you tap the - you'd
accept other terms and conditions and we
let you know that we may be using the
location of your car to serve you it's
important that car makers work to make
this as transparent and easily
explainable as possible and privacy
advocates point out it's on us to start
thinking about cars for what they've
become their data generating devices so
the truth is that yes our cars are
learning more about us but what they
learn may save our lives
a lot of those sensors that collect data
are for the new safety features and
vehicles like collision avoidance up
here up front but triple-a is finding
that that comes with a hidden cost and
that is if you hit anything it can raise
your repair bills by up to three
thousand dollars that study found one
vehicle was a fifty thousand dollar
vehicle had a relatively minor hit here
on the left front the repair bill was
thirty four grand
Nora Wow Chris thank you you know if you
use something like Waze or some other
you know system that navigating system
you're ready transmitting a lot of data
but this is fascinating yeah I like that
all right it's fascinated by that idea
that that there's a possible up side
which is the better the driver you are
the lower your insurance companies it's
not all moment you were fascinated by
the pre-order at McDonald's you can
that's that's a given yeah I mean things
are made now exactly if they could do it
anywhere if you just open the window and
keep driving and they throw it through
the window to make it even faster for
those of us they have to get to work
sorry am i right Chris thank you so much